let's deploy an esprit de corps app to a  Cuban test cluster on Google container  engine first in cloud shell created to  burn this cluster  as cluster is setting up create an  asp.net core web app restore and publish  the app to get a self-contained DLL  inside publish folder create a docker  file docker file builds on the official  Google image for s brodnik or apps build  the local image using google container  builder this publishes the image to  Google container repository that we can  use from our kubernetes cluster later  finally create a cubist deployment with  damage  and expose it to the outside world  in a few seconds your app will be  running in humanity's  thanks for watching